this is the first time I've seen it in
imax and watching the movie today I was
seeing details I haven't even noticed in
our high-end the effects reviews let's
go let's go oh did you want it all right
i'll let you i'll let you rest
unbelievable i'm still kind of blown
away hey it's a huge deal for me i'm a
comedy guy and comedy is always kind of
said to need to be small and I've always
felt like why does comedy have to be
small i can't comedy be huge i really
felt like this was the one that we could
really just kind of take it to the next
level for me it was just figuring out
how can we tell them a small story in
the biggest possible way and how can we
make those giant effects be in service
of our characters and of the comedy
making it funnier but also making it
exciting and keeping this Giants go go
on to take off don't piss off the ghost
really when movies are told on a giant
scale you want the experience of seeing
them to be an event and what I max gives
us is that lost giant movie house
experience then it takes it to the you
know enth degree with the giant sound
and then with this amazing 3d the imax
experience just took what we already
loved and just took it up one hundred
percent
what I love about imax is just it really
creates this weirdly intimate experience
between you and the characters you
really get pulled into the screen
because the screen is everywhere is your
entire field of vision and the imax
experience really does what we as
filmmakers desperately try to do which
is to pull an audience into a film to
make them forget about the outside world
for the two hours that they're with us
normally a movie is confined by the
letterbox that the movie was shot it but
what my team did with our effects is
have those effects break out of the
frame proton beams they will break out
of ghosts will actually break through it
and come towards us okay you sweaty
freaks about to save you from that it's
some kind of crazy alchemy that happens
with IMAX it's just night and day over
the experience that you get in a regular
theater I wish there was a way that
every single person on the planet could
see it this way
you